we find it difficult to make our way
back toward that communion but because
we are designed for it and because God
desires it for us and is working to
bring it about once we be able to once
we begin to cooperate with God in that
project that mutual project we see good
results and good fruits coming from that
and that's really what the Orthodox
Christian church is all about is helping
that to happen in people's lives that's
why we're here that's why we do what we
do
hello everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sockin we are on site
in the beautiful Sioux Falls South
Dakota we are now going to be talking
about Orthodox Christianity we have
father Sava joining us on the show hi
Ella thank you so good to see you again
my friend thank you for inviting me to
your show it's an honor to have you on
thank you sir thank you thank you and
for those that don't know father Sava
Lida is a priest at the Transfiguration
Greek Orthodox Church in Sioux Falls
South Dakota he has been a priest for 16
years and you can find the links in the
bio below to the transfiguration GOC dot
org as well as the Facebook page
father Sava let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world give it to a part
answer Alan to that question that good
question
as an Orthodox Christian
I'm deeply optimistic about the ultimate
direction of our world because it is the
good creation of our God who loves us
and desires that all should make their
way back to him
and I believe that he is well able to
accomplish that desire for all who are
willing and so in the long run I'm quite
optimistic about the direction of the
world and the short one however I see
that the world is in great turmoil
there's a lot of confusion there's a lot
of dysfunction people are set against
one another at all levels of society
those who rule often take advantage of
those who are ruled those who have money
and power often take advantage of those
who don't in order to increase their
wealth at the
expense of the poor there's good
indication that the natural environment
is suffering because of our unwise
actions in the last hundred years I
don't know about that myself I'm not a
scientist but I look around and see
what's happening and I have questions
about that too and so I think in the
short run I am NOT optimistic about the
future of the world our ability to wreak
immune with God the divine that can
potentially heal so many of the issues
that we have in our world absolutely yes
we Orthodox Christians believe that we
are designed by God our Creator for
communion with God and with each other
which means the deepest possible healthy
relationship and that because mainly
because of our own pride but also
because of the general brokenness of
God's good creation we find it difficult
to make our way back toward that
communion but because we are designed
for it and because God desires it for us
and is working to bring it about once we
be able to once we begin to cooperate
with God in that project that mutual
project we see good results and good
fruits coming from that and that's
really what the Orthodox Christian
church is all about is helping that to
happen in people's lives that's why
we're here that's why we do what we do
could it be that the divine creation
that is our world is meant for this
beautiful journey that we go through in
realizing that we all come from God and
Rika Muni with that is that the purpose
of this creation indeed indeed yes the
Apostle Paul writes that the whole of
creation is groaning with longing for
the revealing of the children of God by
which he means exactly what we're
talking about the renewal of our our God
designed communion with with our Creator
God the Holy Trinity yes indeed so we we
emphatically do believe that and we see
that and not only theoretically is that
the case but in actual fact when we
begin to live in the way that the church
teaches for us to live in humility in
love in self-denial in putting others
ahead of ourselves
considering ourselves the least of all
then this really starts to pick up some
momentum and we see the healing of God's
creation beginning with ourselves
because human beings are the crown of
God's good creation and creation is
broken precisely through our brokenness
as a result of our brokenness so when we
begin to be healed and we see parts of
the world around us beginning to be
healed as well it's not an accident for
example that if you go to an Orthodox
Christian monastery you will usually
find the buildings to be surrounded by
beautiful plants of various kinds
flowers and trees and so forth
resembling an earthly paradise and so
that where prayer is active where people
are drawing close to God that has
repercussions
the natural world around us and when we
all have our unique communions with God
there are different healing processes
that occur for each of us due to what
we've been dealt since we were born what
would we say is a good healing modality
methodology mm-hmm the church in her
wisdom offers us a variety of means of
being healed of the the corruption to
use a very strong word the corruption
that leads to death and the
disintegration of our being
you know God and took on himself
our human flesh in order to overcome
this corruption and in in order to
destroy death and in fact he gave
himself over to death he the deathless
one the one who cannot die died as a man
in order to destroy death and open to us
the possibility of living deathless Lee
and so we Orthodox Christians say that
death does not truly exist yes we die
biologically but a human being cannot
die eternally because God who sustains
us in life wills that we should live
eternally as he is eternal and that in
the end our souls and bodies will be
reunited through the resurrection we
can't say a lot of that because about
that because we have not experienced it
directly but that we will be reunited
you reunited with our bodies which will
be in corrupt
all that is that they won't be subject
to death decay disease and so for all
the things that afflict us now now how
do we get from here to there which is
really your question I think the church
invites us first of all as our Lord
Jesus Christ says if anyone would be my
disciple if anyone wants to walk with me
let him deny himself take up his cross
and follow me
and so a life of constant repentance to
use a Christian word that is of constant
turning away from the way that leads to
death and turning back toward God who is
the creator and giver of life that's
what repentance really means on life of
constant repentance which means self
denial a denial of our our our desire to
exalt ourselves as the devil exalted
himself and rebelled against God so we
turn away from that desire and in
repentance we humble ourselves and we
take up our our own cross and follow
Jesus Christ now what is my cross that
can vary from person to person but I
would say that my cross consists of the
things in my life that are either sent
by God or permitted by God in order to
bring me to salvation to healing and
health and communion with God and that
that's a different thing for each person
because we're broken in different ways
aren't we and so our Lord in His
goodness and with his comprehensive
knowledge of us because he knows us
better than we know ourselves since just
what is needed for us some of those
things are very hard that's what we call
them crosses
but so the challenges are viewed as
trousers even the sufferings yes yes
because God sees what we need to a to
experience and to endure in order to be
fixed in order to be healed
he sees precisely that and that's what
he's always offering to us and if we're
able to receive that with gratitude and
humility from God then it will do the
intended work in us if we rebel against
it and complain against it then it will
just make us bitter and angry probably
and lead to more misery and brokenness
and death you see so that's what our
Lord is inviting us to do when he says
take up your cross that is accept these
things that are being offered to you for
your salvation from my hand and you use
this word rejection of the self did
self-denial and meaning being self less
being also understanding the illusion of
this self the unity of everything and
the perpetual servitude that one can be
in towards humanity towards our world
and then that being one of the most if
not the most divine then calling mm-hmm
yes oh we could say it this way may be
that each human heart has a tendency to
create idols that is false gods gods
that do not exist and have no power to
deliver us from anything but rather
deliver us only into slavery and to
servitude to Nothings and one of those
false gods is our ego our tendency to
exalt ourselves and to set ourselves up
as the criterion of every
that is real that is good and to serve
ourselves alone and to organize our
whole existence around serving our our
own ego
so that is perhaps the first Idol that
has to go that has to be destroyed and
after that there are many other idols
that that we manufacture for ourselves
that's another another aspect of the of
the project of living as an Orthodox
Christian is that we we seek to worship
only the Creator not the creature not
what he has created including ourselves
and beginning with ourselves is they
interesting so God is uncreated
uncreated we are created yeah creatures
yes yes God is the only uncreated one
God exists eternally as one God in three
persons one eternal being who has
revealed himself to us in three persons
co-equal Co eternal the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
the famous Holy Trinity the Holy Trinity
guess that's not something that human
beings have made up if one was to I
suppose to come up with some kind of
conception of God I I really doubt that
he would come up with something like the
Holy Trinity and I think that is for me
and you at least an argument in in favor
of the accuracy and reality of this
revelation of God his self revelation he
has revealed himself to us as one God in
three persons as an eternal uncreated
communion of three persons the Father
who is the source of the divinity the
eternal being the son who is co eternal
with the father who is begotten
from the father eternally so that there
were no there was never a time never up
when when he did not exist and the Holy
Spirit who proceeds from the father and
together with the father and the son is
eternally worshiped and glorified this
is how we are taught to speak of God to
name God and so we can say that the name
of the God that Christians worship is
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
but we are not try theists we are
monotheists we worship one God but who
has revealed himself to us in this way
and taught us to name him in this way
does that make sense
it's always in perpetual kindergarten
school yeah yeah so we're talking here
about about things that are at the edge
of our possibility to speak of you
understand you know our language fails
not far beyond this point there's
nothing really more that we can say
about God or know about God in his
eternal being than what we've just said
that he is Father Son and Holy Spirit
now as God reveals himself to us in time
in history by through the Incarnation
but the second person of the Holy
Trinity the son of God the eternal son
of God taking on our flesh from the Holy
Virgin Mary and becoming a human being
the real human being while at the same
time being God we can say thing a lot of
things about that that revelation of God
because our Lord Jesus Christ not only
was born into the world as one of us and
grew up as we all did you know and
became a man gradually but he he he
endured all the things that we endured
all the the vicissitudes of life the
changes and chances of life as an
all prayer says as we as we do endure
but he he was not he was not diminished
by any of it in becoming a man he
certainly humbled himself being God he
humbled himself and this is the the
great paradox and beauty of the
Christian faith is that God is not
someone far away from us who in
arbitrary ways exercises power over us
in ways that we can't understand and
that just frustrate us
Senta and make us angry no that's not
who God is God has revealed himself to
us in Jesus Christ as a man and and as a
God at the same time and as the God
above all who loves us and who gives
himself for us even unto death so that's
that's the center of our Christian faith
that's what it's all about
and this is another reason why then this
Jesus Christ is key because then it
gives us a greater idea of what our
divine reality is yes yes in Jesus
Christ we learn who God is if we want to
know what God is like we don't we don't
speculate we don't philosophize but we
we look at the books of the Gospels the
four Gospels Matthew Mark Luke and John
and reading those Gospels together with
the letters of Apostle Paul and the
other writings in the New Testament we
see who Jesus Christ is we see who God
is in Jesus Christ and so if we want to
know if God is everything that we need
to know about God is revealed in him in
Jesus where Jesus Christ was written
about Jesus Christ through the through
the teachings ah well the Gospels are
our four in number and they describe the
life of Jesus Christ
telling pretty much the same story but
from different points of view it's st.
mark wrote the first gospel it is
believed simply because his is the
shortest we don't know that his was the
first but much of his gospel is included
in the Gospels of st. Matthew and Saint
Luke with additional material for
example all the stories that we hear at
Christmas about the conception Jesus
Christ the birth of Jesus Christ and so
forth those are in the Gospels of
Matthew and Luke my material is not in
Mark's Gospel it's not in John's Gospel
so each of them differs in its contents
even though it tells the same story it's
like you know you have four witnesses to
an event you know some something happens
and four people are standing at
different places and they are
eyewitnesses to this event do you think
they will tell exactly the same story
when they're interviewed later well only
if they get together in a room and
decide on the story otherwise they're
going to tell it differently from their
different point of view and also we
believe that each of the the writers of
the Gospels was writing for a particular
early Christian group a community a
church a local church and told the story
to serve the needs of that that early
Christian community this is where the
game of telephone begins this is where
so then the signal is over time we're
trying to retain as much of that initial
lineage as possible because 2,000 years
later it's really there's a lot of the
game of telephones been played for a
long time that's a
try and get back to that initial lineage
yeah I like that a metaphor very much
because we've all played that game or
something similar and we know what
happens in a very short time is that the
message becomes distorted almost beyond
recognition sometimes in a very short
time great care was taken by the first
Christians that this should not happen
now
things weren't written down for quite a
while after the Lord Jesus Christ walked
the earth it's it's a fact that the
Bible itself as we have it now is a
collection of books of some distinct
writings was not not really organized
until maybe the end of the fourth
century if I recall correctly and had
the official approval of the church as a
collection of books and letters to be
read in the churches before that these
things circulated by word of mouth first
of all these stories about the life and
teachings and death and resurrection of
Jesus Christ among the early Christian
communities much of the New Testament is
letters that were written for example by
Apostle Paul in his apostolic work where
he traveled a lot throughout the
Mediterranean areas and and and began
Christian communities in those places
and then as he traveled on to the next
place sometimes he would write a letter
back to the group of first Christians
that he had established in in in another
place and and so these letters and many
many other writings too for that matter
circulated in the in the early years of
Christianity and eventually some of them
were approved by the leaders of the
church the bishops meeting in council as
being the ones that ought to be read in
church the others maybe were
good for reading such as a document
called the D ducky the teaching of the
Twelve Apostles it didn't make it into
the New Testament but it's very good to
read it's full good wisdom and and also
a document called the Shepherd of hermas
a man called Hermes and and writings
like this are within the tradition of
the church but not included in the New
Testament that is they're not read in
the services of the church and that's
the distinction of what is Holy
Scripture what is read during the
service of the reg is Holy Scriptures
the registry you know as we aim to then
document God revealing himself through
Jesus Christ as we try and document that
what were some of the key things that
were documented about God through you
being revealed through Jesus Christ well
to answer that I could simply refer you
to the four Gospels so because it's all
there
about his conception his miraculous
conception without human seed without a
human father it's the teaching of the
church as recorded in the Gospels that
he was conceived of the Virgin Mary she
was a young woman she had lived a very
sheltered life after being born of aged
parents like many of the people in the
Old Testament were kind of miraculously
well absolutely miraculously a born of a
couple that were beyond the normal time
of childbearing that's not written in in
the gospel by the way that her parents
were old and had her in old age that's
part of the memory of the church that
was not written down in the Gospels but
she as she was born in that way and then
at a certain time she was taken in under
the protection of an old man called
Joseph who was a kinsman of hers and
they were betrothed simply because in
that time a woman who was growing up
needed to be under the protection of a
man
and indeed in the societies in that part
of the world today in the Middle East
it's still the case that each woman
lives her life with a man as her point
of reference in the Arab societies for
example that's the way it is
so as she conceived she bore a son and
he was called Jesus Christ according to
the words of the angel who revealed this
tool to her that's what's recorded in
the New Testament immediately when the
world took notice of this the powers of
the world and the person of the Roman
governor of the area tried to find the
child and put him to death because he
thought that he was a threat to earthly
authority and indeed he was later on his
own people the leaders of his own people
would seek to put him to death and in
the end they would succeed in handing
him over to be crucified by the Roman
authorities because again it was a
threat perceived by them as a threat to
their established Authority and way of
doing things and so this began very
early on when he was still a baby and it
said that he and his mother and his
guardian Saint Joseph had to flee to
Egypt all the way to Egypt to escape the
threat of being done to death but the
soldiers sent by King Herod and so his
his life was always lived in in in
danger and danger from the beginning so
he grew up and he emerged into the world
into the into the public eye we could
say with the event of his baptism by a
man called John who is baptizing people
in the Jordan River offering them
baptism as a sign of repentance of
turning back toward God
and st. John was sent by God to prepare
his way that is to prepare the people's
hearts for God's appearance in their
myths and one day while John was
baptizing people that is immersing them
in the water of the Jordan Jesus Christ
appeared to be baptized with the other
people and John recognized who he was he
knew that he was the Messiah the
promised Savior of Israel
promised through the prophets and he
said it's not right that I should
baptize you you know I'm not worthy to
do this but Jesus Christ says it's okay
you should do this I want you to do this
in order to fulfill all righteousness
that is to show the right way to do
things and our Lord in all things is an
example to us of of how to do things
properly and so even though he didn't
need to be cleansed he didn't need to be
baptized he didn't need to repent of
anything because he was perfectly
sinless nevertheless he submitted to be
baptized and when he was baptized it
says the heavens opened and the voice a
voice came forth saying this is my
beloved Son in whom I am well pleased
this is the voice of God the Father that
everyone heard according to one gospel
everybody heard it according to another
gospel only he heard it but in any case
the voice came forth and then the Holy
Spirit represented in the form of a dove
a bird he came down and alighted upon
him now the father is not a voice the
father is not a sound the Holy Spirit is
not a bird neither the father nor the
Holy Spirit became incarnate that is
joined themselves to our created world
but on that occasion their presence was
testified to by this voice and by this
bird and what did the voice say this is
my beloved Son in whom I am well
and so in this way God revealed himself
right off the bat when our Lord Jesus
Christ was baptized after that he went
around doing good he preached to the
people good news that the kingdom of God
was very near that is God isn't far away
he hasn't forgotten you he's not angry
with you he loves you in fact and and as
a demonstration of that love Jesus
Christ healed people of physical
diseases He healed them of spiritual
diseases in the form of being possessed
by demons
sometimes he cast the demons out they
had not no defense against him because
he he is their creator and he has
authority over them and so he freed
people from physical illness from
spiritual illness he also spoke to those
in authority who were abusing their
authority weren't serving the people in
love as God had appointed them to do
people like the priests of the time of
the Jewish people the the people called
the Pharisees the Sadducees the scribes
these were groups of people who were in
positions of honor and authority over
the people but they weren't doing their
job properly at that time and so our
Lord Jesus Christ rebuked them and
called them to repentance especially and
he preached good news to the poor as it
says liberation to the captives and for
every one he had a word of salvation to
speak and he would say the word that
each person needed to hear in order to
begin their journey back to God often
his teaching was in the form of stories
that we call parables
one of the most famous is the parable of
the prodigal son a younger brother of
two brothers who lived in his father's
house but decided that he didn't want to
live there anymore and he asked his
father to divide what would be his
inheritance between him and his brother
so that he could have it now he was
really in essence asking his father to
to act as though he were already dead
and to give him the money that would
come to him in that case the father very
humbly did so even knowing what kind of
disaster was likely to follow and indeed
the the young younger brother the son
goes into a foreign land where nobody
knows him and he spends all of the money
on riotous living it says and we can
imagine what what he did with it he went
through it very quickly and he finds
himself destitute and and gets a job
from one of the local people feeding
pigs which is about the worst thing that
can happen to a Jew you know because
pigs and Jews don't mix they don't they
don't associate with pigs much less eat
them so there he is in the pigsty
covered in mud
he's hungry he's tired his cone is only
well what has happened really the he
represents our human nature that has
turned away from God and wandered to a
distant land a faraway land and has
spent its life on vanity on nothing
basically you know and finds itself
destitute naked hungry cold lonely and
not only that but in bondage to the
demons you know represented by the pigs
but a miracle happens then and the story
the young man says why am I here he
comes to himself it says he returns to
himself he says why am I here even the
servants in my father's house have
enough to eat you know they have
everything they need why am I here
I don't have to be here I can swallow my
pride I can stand up and I can start the
long journey back to my father's house
and he makes a little plan he says when
I get there I'm going to say to my
father father I've sinned against heaven
and before you I'm not worthy anymore to
be called your son please make me as one
of your hired servants and this is his
plan and he's as he goes on the road
toward his father's house he rehearses
this little speech that he wants to make
but he never gets to make it because as
soon as his father catches sight of his
son returning and we get the sense that
he's been watching for him ever since he
left the father runs out to greet him
and he embraces him and the son starts
to make the speech father I have sinned
before heaven and before Earth I'm not
worthy to be called your son the father
is immediately calling his servants to
bring fine clothing for the boy a ring
for him new shoes for his feet clean him
up prepare a banquet because my son was
lost and now he's found he was dead now
he's alive and so he makes this
marvelous feast there's another part of
the story about the older brother the
son who stayed at home and he's and his
response to to this event of the return
of the younger brother do you suppose
he's happy to see his brother no not at
all not at all he's sulking outside the
house while he hears all the party going
on and he asks one of the servants
what's going on he said well your
brother's come back and your dad is
throwing a party and he goes into the
Father there the father comes out to him
excuse me just as he came out to the
youngest
if I remember correctly the father comes
out and says what's the matter my son
and he complains that this son of yours
who wasted all your money on harlots and
so forth and now he comes back and
you'll give him this big party where
I've always been here with you serving
you faithfully and you never gave me
even a goat so I could have a party with
my friends he's bitter and he's angry
and he's just he's so angry he can't
even call this man his brother anymore
this son of yours he says was wasted all
your living and what does the father say
to him to show his love which is as
great for that son as it is for the
other one he says my son you're always
with me all that I have is yours was it
not right that when your brother came
back we should we should rejoice because
he was dead he's resurrected from the
dead you know practically speaking so
that's how the story ends and I hope
I've told it accurately but you get the
gist it's it's beautiful and simple and
yet immensely powerful we can all relate
to it you know just on that literal
level and also you know in the broader
way of seeing how it describes our
corrupted human nature and and its
restoration in Christ so this is how our
Lord taught the people Wow the amount of
story that exists that has so many
profound learning lessons embedded in
them is just gorgeous and to be able to
go back and to and to take these stories
and to find deep meaning in them in
driving our own ethical and moral and
spiritual evolution ourselves because
hearing things like that make us reflect
on our own behavior and
seek out a more righteous way of living
and also to mean like you look
describing as well this this God
revealing himself through Jesus Christ
and then are documenting of the way that
Jesus Christ is is healing and is
bringing this light to unto others and
then having others be able to commune
back and go through that process of
realizing divinity so let's let's
explore the Holy Spirit what is the Holy
Spirit we speak of Lord the Holy Spirit
as the third person of the Holy Trinity
along with the father and the son Co
aeternam co-equal uncreated who in the
in the Creed which is this great
statement of faith that was composed by
the church by the fourth century and was
completed the the Creed speaks of the
Holy Spirit as the Lord the giver of
life who spoke by the prophets so the
Holy Spirit speaks through the prophets
of the Hebrew times the Old Testament
times in order to correct the people and
to recalibrate them we could say from
time to time and they always needed
recalibrating as all of us do because we
we get kind of wonky you know we go
astray and we need to be recalibrated
that is the work of our Lord the Holy
Spirit and also to proclaim through the
prophets the coming of God in the flesh
Jesus Christ that
is his job - now after the incarnation
in the time now of the church the Holy
Spirit empowers first of all the
Apostles to go out into all the world
and proclaim the death of death in Jesus
Christ to proclaim the possibility of
the restoration of human nature from its
corruption and and the death of death so
that we have the possibility of eternal
life with God now these apostles with
the exception of st. Paul were not
educated men several of them were
fishermen no they were just ordinary
humble people how did they receive the
gifts that they needed to go out and do
this mighty work to go out - to distant
lands and places where they did not even
know the local language and and speak to
the people about these things in such a
way that they received the word it was
by the power and the gifts of the Holy
Spirit so the Holy Spirit is it's jobs
simply is to continue to bear witness to
God's revelation of himself in Jesus
Christ yeah that's that's what the Holy
Spirit is and we don't say a lot more
about him than that because he hasn't
become incarnate just as the father
hasn't become incarnate and so on in the
beautiful icon or holy picture of the
three angels drawn by saint andrei
rublyov in medieval times which is the
great one of the great treasures of
russia we see three angels and
allegorically they represent the three
persons of the Holy Trinity
we don't say they are the Holy Trinity
because the father and the Holy Spirit
can be depicted because they've never
taken on flesh but nevertheless the the
son the central angelic figure is
it's very solid looking very opaque in
the way that same andrei rublyov' has
drawn him painted him whereas the other
two figures that may correspond we may
say to the Father and to the Holy Spirit
are more ethereal more translucent
almost to indicate that they they never
were incarnate and so that's kind of a
way of indicating through the means of
painting the truth of of who God is so
this leads us to then asking one of I
think most important questions here
which is that how do we have this
religious pluralism all coexist that we
have this idea of a God or source that
all of us have our own unique
relationship with rika muting with that
and there is all different religions
there's even science that says this pain
comes from a Big Bang 13.8 billion years
ago how do you see these things
coexisting sure that's that's the big
question one of the big questions of our
time isn't it when the world is the
world's population is being stirred up
so to speak and because of the the great
mobility that we have had in the last
century and a half let's say that really
did not exist before that at least not
in that to the degree that we have it
now peoples are moving about and
encountering one another and having to
live side by side in ways that they
never did before and so it it represents
an immense opportunity for all of us to
be enriched by the wisdom of one another
but I'm afraid that more often what
happens is that we
we we enter into conflict with each
other because of different cultural
assumptions different beliefs different
allegiances so for example one of the
great forces in the world today
alongside Christianity is Islam which is
a very different way of understanding
God the world human nature human destiny
from from the Christian way of
understanding these things it's a
different revelation a revelation of a
very different character which creates a
culture of a very different character
from Christian culture it may be that
these two cultures are irreconcilable I
personally believe that Christian
culture and Muslim culture have a lot to
say to each other and in fact they have
lived side by side in many places in the
world for centuries however it is a fact
that wherever the Muslim culture is the
dominant culture the Christians are
placed in a lower level they have great
social disabilities placed on them
millions of them have been martyred in
the Muslims Muslim lands from the time
of the conquest after Mohammed until
today it's still going on and we we dare
not brush this under the rug or pretend
that all is sweetness and light because
it's not the borders between
Christianity and Islam are always almost
always bloody however Christians and
Muslims have succeeded in living
together
in peace in various places where they
have a rough parity of population sizes
and they've found ways to live live
together in peace but usually not by
living next door to one another you know
in the same town usually by having
villages that are Christians ones that
are Muslim you know and so forth or
sections of a city where the different
homogenous populations will settle here
in America it's very different because
anybody can buy a house next to anybody
else you know it's it's very easy for a
Christian to buy a house next to a
Muslim and vice versa and so we must
find a way to live together here I think
that is a project that's worthy of our
greatest effort and greatest attention
that same analogy must be also seen at
that global level similarly of like we
need to learn how to live together on
this planet absolutely we do we do I'm
not optimistic of our chances for doing
that because I think if we speak
developmentally about human nature we
are designed to live in tribes for one
of a better word you know that's how we
function best among people who are like
ourselves who share our worldview our
values our religious traditions and so
forth that's how we function most
effectively
it seems to me anyway I'm just offering
my own opinion here and so I think we
have great difficulties in the modern
world because we are not we could say
designed or were not adapted we could
say maybe to to function alongside to
live alongside people with very who have
very different assumptions about reality
than we do we're just not adapted for
that it seems to me
and so that's why we have such
difficulty
think it's not that it's impossible we
can do it and I think as Christians we
are obliged to try to humble ourselves
but and to live with others in peace as
much as we can but at the same time
we're not obliged to allow people who do
not value what we value and are not
interested in living in peace with us to
invade and our land and supplant us
we're not obliged to do that and so it's
finding the way between those two that I
think is important for us and in the
world as it is
you bring up you know Christianity and
Islam which have this history that you
you've described very difficult history
and what about Taoism and Buddhism and
Hinduism and these others that have also
had issues of always but also that seem
to have these deep roots in just the
most meditative flow driven being yes
well as an Orthodox Christian I would
say that God has revealed himself in
many and various ways as it says in the
letter to the Hebrews in the New
Testament he has revealed himself in
many and various ways throughout human
history and including in that and and
and and in Hebrews it speaks
specifically of his revelation of
himself through the prophets of Israel
but I believe that we can extend that
revelation to include all of the ancient
philosophical and religious traditions
of mankind not that any of them is
complete but that each of us each of
them in each of them we can perhaps
recognize foreshadowings of God's
complete revelation of himself in Jesus
Christ there are many things in in those
traditions that we would not recognize
or accept as worth
Christiane's for example the the
egregious polytheism that exists in
hinduism you know where various
attributes of divinity are I guess we
could say reified or identified with a
particular supposed deity you know so
you have this proliferation of thousands
of supposed deity a son that's a mistake
we think that's not accurate to reality
but at the same time you know the for
example the the life cycle has been a
long time since I studied these things
but the idea of there being seasons in a
human's life you know there's the season
when you're young and you're learning to
be a human being
there's the season when you're a
householder and you're preoccupied with
meritum life maybe in raising children
there's a season when you are a worker
primarily and and there's a season then
in all Dage where you're preparing
yourself for death for your departure
from this world and I'm sorry I can't
remember the specifics of the
terminology I studied these things as an
undergraduate a lifetime ago but but you
understand what I'm talking about I
think that that's a very profound and
helpful way of speaking about about
human life because we do change as we
grow older and we experience different
identities almost you could say as we
make our way through our life in this
world and that idea that at the end we
should consciously withdraw from active
life and devote ourselves to the
preparation for what comes next and we
might as Christians speak differently
about what comes next then into us would
for example or Buddhists or Taoist or
whatever but but that that idea of that
schema of human life I think yes it's
something that resonates with me very
strongly because I'm about to I hope
retire from active human life in a few
years and devote myself to getting ready
for what comes next
may God grant
I loved how you described to God
revealing himself through so such a
beautiful variety of potentials and how
then it's in the essences and eyes and
feelings of the seekers that are seeking
that communion with God revealing
yourself that then are able to identify
all these different potential modalities
I want to also express how and hear how
you feel about this that then some of
the seekers are attempting to then
commune with God expressing himself
through science through mathematics and
attempting to do so by understanding the
the at the most granular level how the
even subatomic particles work how the
inner workings of our biological Makita
mechanisms work and so these are kind of
like the absolute like diver deepers
into all the mechanics and trying to
understand the source code of creation
so in a sense that's also communing with
God revealing himself through math and
through science and so that's another
one of those coexist can that coexist
could that potentially help bridge
together all of the religious pluralism
with which science could science of
spirituality marry together and then how
do you feel about all of that well
that's that's a lot to try to get my
arms around it's a big question island
but I'll give it a shot you know I think
it was place Pascal day the
Renaissance of ah so foreign and
unchristian
belieber faithful Christian who said
that scientific investigation is
thinking God's thoughts after him if I'm
remembering correctly and I've always
I've always kind of liked that phrase
thinking God's thoughts after him
because God being the creator of all as
we Christians believe him to be he's
described in the scriptures in the
Gospel of st. John with the word logos
the word which means word or reason or
speech this Greek word logos is often
left untranslated and of course it's the
word that's the review there's at the
root of many of our words theology the
logos of God
psychology though the logos of the human
soul they're the reason or the teaching
or the the inner inner workings of the
created reality of so God is logos God
is the one who speaks things into
existence God said let there be light
and there was light
it says famously in the first chapter of
the Bible in Genesis so I think that
these things naturally it's natural to
try to consider these things together
however I would say that the things
being revealed by scientific
investigation are becoming so numerous
that it's impossible for one person to
know them to begin with only a very
small part of them you know God's
creation is so fast and so that both at
the McCarron micro level yeah that it's
it's impossible for the finite human
mind to grasp it
which i think is evidence for God's
being myself I think the best scientist
is the one who is the most humble
intellectually who always thinks of his
or her work as being provisional and
being susceptible to be replaced by
something else that is discovered or a
better understanding and always to need
to be tested by empirical verification
if it's possible so in in all these ways
I see that you know the pursuit of
science which means knowledge it comes
from the Latin word which simply means
knowledge true of true the truth the
true nature of things if it's done
honestly and humbly according to the
scientific method itself is in no way
opposed to our our view of how the world
is or how God is truth is one I like to
say the truth is one as God is one and
any honest pursuit of truth will lead to
the same place to the same truth that's
how I see these things I'm not sure I
answered your question but definitely
this is this is how I think about these
things but I don't know anything about
them really I just I'm just one person
who looks at the world and and tries to
make sense of things like everybody else
question along the way on that subject
would be then how about then the story
of Orthodox Christianity in terms of
God's creation versus what science says
about the evolution of humanity from our
ancestors from
from the Big Bang to the to the atoms
and planets the Stars and then from
seeing go salt a multi so organisms yes
yes yes going from a kind of an
undifferentiated very simple but highly
energetic reality to a much more
different very differentiated and
complex and environment in which the
energy is more dispersed than it was at
the beginning which if I understand
correctly is kind of how scientists now
are looking at things I don't know a lot
about that that I read a little bit it
seems to me that that is not in any way
at odds with what we believe as Orthodox
Christians about God's creation of the
world from the beginning until now and
incidentally when we speak of creation
we don't just mean of God's creating the
initial conditions or the initial stuff
but we mean a continuing process by
which God's uncreated energy keeps
maintains the world in existence keeps
it going from moment to moment if it
didn't everything would fall apart
we know the attendance ii-in in the
physical world is to award not toward
increased complexity and differentiation
but when the energy is drawn out of it
it it collapses into dust entropy you
know if I understand things correctly
and so it seems to me that in order for
the world to be maintained in being this
creative energy uncreated energy
uncreated creative energy if we can say
so or God's preserving energy we could
we could Turman
must continually be injected into the
the world has to be so fused with this
energy otherwise it would collapse back
into nine being that's my understanding
of things there are other Orthodox
Christians who who would take issue with
what I just said probably which doesn't
bother me at all the church has no
official teaching on these things we say
that we believe in one God who created
the heavens and the earth and that's
that's all that were obliged to believe
formally about these things the church
doesn't teach us how old the world is
for example when it began it teaches
that the world began by God's will and
by his action the God that this world
will as it is now will come to an end at
some point
known only to God and we live in between
those times as best we can and maybe
even one of the recent beautiful ways of
seeing what God potentially is that I've
really enjoyed is that we as we evolve
towards complexity that we then have the
ability to then take the initial
substrate that created creation and then
embed that in our complexity to cycle
another creation and then that is just a
cyclical process you know yes we were
talking about that the other day weren't
we yeah yeah as Christians we understand
history and pretty much linearly as ice'
mentioned a minute ago you know from its
beginning to its endpoint and then all
of it though contained if we can put it
this way within the realm of eternity
which is not like our existence now you
know we live historically now yesterday
today tomorrow maybe tomorrow with
No all we have the only time we have
really is now this moment when we're
talking with each other we don't know
whether there'll be a next moment or not
and so that's how how Christians
generally think of or understand reality
however within that linear span of
history
and within that eternal now of eternity
can there be recurring cycles and I
would say certainly if we read the the
books of the Old Testament the history
of old Israel for example we see cycles
of flourishing of return to God and
faith in God and trust in God and a
reaping of the benefits of all that in
the daily lives of the people and then
we see that degenerating into times of
apostasy a fleeing from God fleeing
toward idols created by men's hands and
so forth and the slavery that the people
experienced as the result of that not
freedom but slavery and then they need
to repent of that and return to God God
sent prophets to remind them of who they
are who God is they repent sometimes
return to God so there is that cyclical
action going on you could say I think in
each of our lives - you know we often
say in orthodoxy that the Christian life
is one of continuous repentance not just
initial repentance when we turn back but
you know when the prodigal son has
returned to his father's house he needs
to be watchful over himself
and make sure when he needs to repent
again in small things that he does so
that he's not tempted to do another big
rebellion and find himself you know in
the midst of swine hungry and cold and
naked
so it was just a few thoughts and
response to your good question yes yes
thank you what about the creation having
both good and evil and then the
interplay of those two within our lives
yes that's a question that has
preoccupied human beings always I think
good and evil the mystery of good and
evil as God has revealed himself to us
we Orthodox Christians believe that God
is good and that God doesn't change that
means that if God was good in the
beginning God is still good we can rely
on God being good tomorrow and of God
being favourably deposed disposed toward
us he's for us he's on our side we can
say God does not change in our work of
salvation it's not our job to change
God's mind that doesn't mean to happen
because God is always for us and I say
this because this distinguishes us as
Eastern Orthodox Christians from some
varieties of Western Christianity where
the praha the project seems to be
precisely to change God's mind either by
doing good work so that you'll see and
then you'll be favorably disposed toward
us or by interposing Jesus Christ
between us and God the Father who is
angry with us and wants to get us so
that he will see his son and the
goodness and beauty of his son and then
change his mind about us this seems to
be the project of certain kinds of
Western Christianity but we don't see
that in in orthodoxy at all if we if if
we in the Bible or in some of the
prayers and hems of the church we talk
about God being angry with us it's
metaphorical it's to remind us
that this is serious business you know
that though God is for us we must be
willing for God to do his good work of
healing and Recreation within our within
our lives if we're not willing God being
very humble and gentle will not run over
us and force us because if you force
someone it's not love it's no longer in
love it's coercion or or oppression you
see so we we understand that God is is
always for us he's always making himself
available was very humbly but we must
open the door we must invite him in you
know to do his good work in us where
does evil come from then God does not
create evil that's clearly the teaching
of the the Christian Church of the east
and the West God does not create evil we
created through our ignorance we are
created through our ignorance and
through our rebellion are fruitless
rebellion against against reality really
against God who only wills good things
for us yes in those ways we created for
ourselves and it makes for a good story
that we created it well you know I make
more challenging yes yes there are there
are such stories in the Bible beginning
with the story of our first created man
and woman our first parents Adam and Eve
which is a powerful story if we
understand that it is the story not just
of the first humans but of every one of
us you know it's a story of our of our
willful ignorance in the face of God's
gift of himself to us our willful
ignorance through which we we make an
idol that we prefer to God to the
reality of
and to the reality of what he has
created us to be so in that of course
that pattern is is repeated again and
again throughout history it's documented
in the scriptures it's documented in
history it's documented you know by our
own consciousness of how we how we are
each of us if we come to to the
knowledge of that and for not living in
oblivious Monsieur know we'll come to
the knowledge of that and we'll wake up
and we'll say we'll come to ourselves
most babe I will arise and go to my
father's house yeah yeah how gorgeous it
is that we all get to experience life
and consciousness and all these
beautiful gifts of family and friends
and food water air all these types of
things and all these things are good
very good God shows us here it's every
week up to how beautiful it is and yeah
yes double night to finally commune back
with me wood will roll then at all these
bifurcating moments of choice that we
have of of pursuing a certain thing of
pursuing another one these potential
choices not always binary and good and
evil but they're altering moments in our
life trajectory
what role does freewill play in those
choices and where does determinism fall
into the picture yes well we understand
as Orthodox Christians that we each have
a choice sometimes it's very difficult
for us to choose God to choose the way
that leads back to God it's not easy for
the prodigal son to get up from the mud
in the midst of the pigs and say I will
arise and go to my father's house it's
not easy and sometimes it's a lot harder
than others in the case of someone who
is enslaved for example to some kind of
addiction it's very
are very hard to break out of that
slavery God will help but we have to
really want it we have to really want it
and we have to make our own feeble
effort to and enlist the help of others
whom God sends to us but it is always
possible for us to choose the good to
know the good and to choose the good
someone asked me in just yesterday what
about in the case of a person who is a
psychopath is there a possibility of
repentance and redemption for such a
person in other word could such a person
be healed by having that part of the
personality that is missing or is
corrupted to be restored
I said theoretically yes but how often
does it happen you know possibly yes oh
yeah we have to we have to believe that
everyone is as the possibility of being
restored having the image of God in
which is created or she has created to
be restored and perfected to its
original beauty but sometimes it's very
hard to see how that happens at least in
human terms
but with God everything is possible yeah
yeah
often in orthodoxy we speak of the the
life of a human being in Christ as being
cleaned or or cleansed of the things
that don't belong purified the things
that don't belong on us and in us in our
lives I'm just as maybe a picture an
icon that has hung in a church for
centuries maybe somewhere in Eastern
Europe has been there for five centuries
let's say a holy picture it's not the
way the artist painted it
well it is but it's all covered with
soot from candles and lamps and incense
and all in just dust for centuries and
centuries and so you can hardly see
what's there what the painter put there
so what needs to happen to that picture
does it need to be taken out and chopped
up and burned no no it needs to be
purified yeah take a cleanse so it can
shine with its original beauty that it's
maker intended and that's a perfect
analogy I think for us series what has
to happen for us that we must allow our
Lord the Holy Spirit to do his good work
in us which is sometimes very painful
the process of the restoration of a
picture is fraught with many dangers you
know to use that to push the analogy
maybe a little further it might hurt us
to be to be cleansed because some of
these things have become so much a part
of us that that we come to believe this
is who we are you know we identify
ourselves as of that which we are not
that which doesn't belong in us and so
it can be very painful to have those
things generally being removed but
that's what must happen if we are to
shine with our original beauty just like
the the restoration of a beautiful
painting yeah takes place with great
care and gentleness and an attempt not
to damage anything of the original there
remains and when it's finished I saw a
video on YouTube just the other day so
I'm thinking about that a Renaissance
painting that was was restored in just
that way at the end the various places
where the image had just disappeared it
flaked off after they got done cleaning
the whole thing and going it all
together again
the restorer took a fine brush and and
some paints and just gent
they painted in this part
again very very respectfully and not in
any kind of ostentatious way but with
the idea to reproduce the original
recreate the original so everything
would would function harmoniously again
it was it was a miracle to see really
and that's the miracle that can happen
for us - yes I really love the analogy
of the painting that is very very very
well you dust it off and and cleansed
although that that process may it's
clearing our channel tank or the divine
there may be some some triggers or
traumas in that process that we can
integrate and we can repair those in
order for us to heal and not repeat and
as we do that process it's also good
analogies it's like a gem very similarly
with the gem were were cleaning the gem
we're making the gem able to shine and
the gem is like us individually being
able to bring our gifts forth into the
world and have the sunlight shine
through the gem and break apart into a
prism and just shine on the planet with
our unique gifts and so I love that that
analogy and it does not come without
hard sincere self work in connection to
the divine as I believed always with
God's help yes Jesus Christ says I am
the light of the world he who believes
in Me will not walk in darkness but have
the light of Life he also says to us you
are the light of the world a city set on
a hill that cannot be hidden and so we
can think of the analogy perhaps of the
Sun the Lord Jesus Christ being the Sun
the source of light and life and warmth
and all good things and we being like
the moon to reflect that light to the
degree that we have been purified and
illumined by his by his light by his His
grace his his power to
to an aluminum to save that's gorgeous
that's gorgeous and then there may even
be we could say that the more that we've
been purified our channel that the more
we are like the full moon that can then
reflect so much that sunlight onto earth
and lo maybe they little more we have
oil within the water that the more it's
like the new moon where there's less
light being able to be reflected what is
it like running the church there's a
process of going to seminary school
there's a process of becoming a deacon
of becoming a priest and then for those
that would like to becoming a bishop
which oversees regional churches and
priests and deacons act as helpers so
how how does this all work and then
there's you know communities in the
areas come that are Christian that come
to the church is to do the practice and
you engage with dozens if not even up to
hundreds of people and act as as as
someone that's trained in the divine to
help them with their communions this is
a beautiful thing and it's also complex
and I'd love for you to talk about it
I'll try I'll try it is a beautiful
thing and I'm thankful constantly to God
for permitting me the privilege to be
his representative so to speak to his
people and also the intercessor for the
people before God's throne because
that's the main work of the priests is
to pray for the people also to to offer
sacrifices to God for the people as we
say which simply means to serve the
services of the church in such a way
that the the things of this world the
things of God's
good creation are offered up to him and
transfigured by him and returned to us
as as life-giving realities the the
premier example of course is the divine
liturgy which in the West is called the
mass it's the service of of it's the
premier service of the church the
central action of the people of God by
which we bring ourselves first of all
together into the temple of God offering
ourselves to him for him to purify us
and aluminous and drawers and drawers
increasingly closer to him and then send
us out into the world to be his
witnesses his hands so to speak we do
this in an interesting way this all
happens in a very interesting way which
was given to us by the Lord Jesus Christ
on the night before he was given over to
death he very simply called his friends
together his 12 disciples and he took a
bit of bread and he said to them he gave
thanks and he broke it and said to them
this is my body which is broken for you
do this esteana mean an omni scene it
says greeked for the recollection of me
and then the same thing with the cup of
wine he took the cup and blessed give
thanks and gave it to them saying this
is the cup of My Blood which is shed
well the New Covenant in my blood which
is shed for you and for many for the
remission of sins do this for the
remembrance of me with this command he
inaugurated the service of the holy
liturgy in which we do the same thing
imitating him we take bread
bread ordinary bread that we've made for
this purpose a cup some wine in it and
we we bless it we pray over it we ask
our Lord the Holy Spirit to sanctify it
and to change it into our Lord's body
and blood according to his promise which
becomes our spiritual food and drink we
receive in in a physical way the
deathless body and blood of Jesus Christ
who has himself destroyed death by his
death and risen and can never die again
we receive that deathlessness into
ourselves in this way every time we
receive Holy Communion it's a very
powerful thing it is as tangible and
taste a bullet as as anything could be
this communion we have with our God who
has for us provided himself to us in
this way physically not just spiritually
in some kind of ethereal way but very
very tangibly and tasted Li in Holy
Communion so that we become one with him
physically and also of course in every
other way but so this is this is the
work of the priest is to sanctify these
the people through these means that God
has made available to us through prayer
through sacrifice through the holy
mysteries or sacraments as we say only
baptism only communion and the other
sacraments well which use some kind of
tangible created physical reality as the
means by which God communicates himself
to us it's very beautiful and and
powerful and you see that God's energies
are imparted to people and their lives
changed as a result
so it's it's a great privilege for a
priest to have a front-row seat to all
of these things you can say and despite
our own unworthiness and inadequacy all
these things happen according to God's
Word and promised through his energy not
our own
so that's it's a beautiful thing to be a
part of and I'm very thankful for it was
there anything else in your question
that I neglected to hit on don't touch
on
nope excellent good good and how about
as we progress into this exponential
technology age there's 8 billion humans
on the planet the geopolitics like you
were describing people are able to fly
to different places and move and live
next to people that they would have
potentially never had the chance to live
next to before the power of the
technologies being democratized and put
in our hands that at unprecedented rates
so how do you see the would be maybe
like a main principle that we could
embody both as children and as adults
that could help us really get through
the complexity of the next couple
decades first of all I I don't want to
assume that this represents progress
from one level of being to another level
of being a higher or better level of
being it may very well represent some
kind of regression for human beings that
the exponential technology era could yes
that's a very we really need to bear in
mind that possibility could to my way of
thinking it's it's equally possible or
maybe even more possible that it is in
fact a regression than any kind of
progression the fact that we have yet to
fully unleash and unlock the potential
of our own biological communion with the
divine and yet we're already going into
the technological appendages of the
Engineering in the neural implants and
yes yes yes and we we run a real risk of
being enslaved by these things that we
have created by the works of our own
hands it's a matter of idolatry again in
many cases I believe I know for example
quite a few young men who are addicted
to video games and I don't use that word
lightly they cannot break away from them
yes and it's not like these are some
kind of profound means of communion with
their own souls or with God no they're
they're they're meaningless really
they're insipid and yet these young it's
almost always young men cannot break
away from them this is a real problem
and just like one example of many many I
mean look how we are with our cell
phones look how we are yeah I mean we
make jokes about and draw cartoons about
it but really it's very serious where we
are conducting an experiment on the
whole whole human race that's
unprecedented and we have no idea the
consequences of it so that's one thing I
would want to say in a kind of a
prophetic mode I would not assume that
this is progress necessarily another
thing I would like to say though perhaps
more gently and optimistically is that
human beings remain human beings we are
the good creation of God we are created
according to the image of God and his
likeness and in his likeness we were
made to resemble God and we know what
God is like in Jesus Christ were made to
be like that so if these very powerful
tools that we create are able in some
ways to help us toward that then thank
God let us use them yes I think that
should be our criterion however
not to make some new technology just
because we can I think there are things
that we can do that we ought not to do
because they may very well end up be
being dehumanizing they may enslave us
oh I don't know much about these things
but that's what I think since you asked
the principle of making technology that
assists us with the communion with the
divine does the spirit come from God and
meets the body for this experience of
life how does that process work disk
disk does our life and consciousness
just emerge from biological evolution do
we have a spirit or soul that sets in to
the body yes certainly we do human
beings are unique in all of creation
I would maintain as an Orthodox
Christian and as a priest we are not
like the other animals even though we
are you know we're very much like the
other animals we can be described for
example as the greatest of the great
apes no that's not an inaccurate
description of a human being but it is
an in a hopefully inadequate description
of a human being because it doesn't it
doesn't speak at all to the aspect of
humanity which is foremost which is that
we are created in the image of our
Creator no other animal is and so while
we are animals obviously I mean it's
obvious to anyone who who studies things
honestly we are like the other animals
were made of the same stuff we have the
same physical processes otherwise they
couldn't test new pharmaceuticals on
other species of animals and to find out
if their work in us so I mean it's it's
obvious that we have biologically
much in common with the other animals
however we are not mere animals
we're not merely physical beings and I
would say the other animals are not
either but that's another discussion but
we are unique among the other animals in
that we correspond to God in our in our
very being
we correspond to God and our very being
we are made to live to be like him
to become more and more like him and to
live in communion with him eternally and
we cannot say that with any certainty
about any other animal so yes we are
unique how that uniqueness came about is
to me a bit of a mystery it is described
in the book of Genesis using different
different images are there different
pictures of different stories for
example in one place it says that God
formed Adam Amin ha Adama from the earth
Adam min ha Adama so that it emphasizes
how Adam the man corresponds to ha Adama
which means the soil the earth in the
hebrew it's very clear that
correspondence it shows that we are made
of the same stuff and experience the
same physical processes as all the rest
of creation but God creates us with his
hands with the other things he speaks
and it is with us
he creates us he forms us out of the
ground I think that's really significant
mm-hmm in the solar the spirit the soul
and the spirit that's described as
coming into the first created man by God
breathing into his nostrils the breath
of life
yes soul is the Spirit of God
that's the enlivening energy of God that
that enters into us
and retake our fourth press our first
breath and for every succeeding breath
you that that breath of God yeah that
that created and sustaining energy of
God which is itself uncreated which is
another odd it's such a going it's such
an interesting fact that you're saying
this because all so many of the other
especially like Buddhism is so adamant
about one's ability to train their focus
or everything and that is God every
breath is God it's a defined gift and
yes every breath is a divine gift and
what would you say is the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world
undoubtedly undoubtedly it is in my view
our Lord Jesus Christ the god man and
his only bride the church that is the
most beautiful thing in the world that I
know of yes whoa this is such a good
conversation father song I think it's
been such a pleasure thank you thank you
so much for coming on show I'd love to
as before we close I'd love to have you
run take us through a prayer sure I
think a good prayer for us to offer at
this point is a very simple prayer that
Orthodox Christians say several times a
day when we pause to pray it's a prayer
that is addressed to our Lord the Holy
Spirit whom we have spoken of today
usually our prayers are addressed to God
the Father or goat the son it really
doesn't matter to whom we address them
because they are all one as we've said
but this prayer is addressed to our Lord
the Holy Spirit and it goes like this
Oh heavenly King comforter the Spirit of
Truth who are in all places filling all
things treasury of good things and give
of life coment abide in us and cleanse
us from every stain and save our souls
all good one in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
one God amen
thank you so much I saw this has been a
big honor and pleasure for me to be able
to bring you on the show and talk to you
share who you are in the teachings of
Orthodox Christianity and so many of the
other aspects of your world for you it's
been a great honor and pleasure for me
to of my friend thank you for inviting
me
it was good to share this time with you
thank you thank you and thank you
everyone for tuning in we really
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments blonde the
episode let us know what you're thinking
we would also love for you to have more
conversations with your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media about Orthodox Christianity
and about the Holy Trinity about all the
things that we talked about today on the
show what the future of all of this is
gonna be like and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe and
support them and help them grow you can
find all of the links below as well
again to the transfiguration greek
orthodox church you can find simulations
links below our patreon or paypal our
cryptocurrency link you can design cool
merch and get paid all those links are
both for the ones in your communities as
well everyone and go and build the
future everyone commune with the divine
and manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon
Wow
[Music]